[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm could be HD here
and these are the new beats solo Pro
headphones hey whoa wait a second I I
thought you hate beets what's going on
huh uh you know what it's kind of funny
the I actually kind of started off like
I really loved beets but then I sort of
swung the other way and then I hated
beets for a while but then I sort of
came back but I don't know I feel like I
have to check these out look at look at
the box that come in which it says solo
pros to call the pros I have to check
them out they come at a bunch of sweet
colors and then the box literally says
more Matt on it as if that's a huge
feature so I I don't know I feel like I
have to alright what does that mean I
can have the Sony's then no no
definitely I'm you can I'll keep using
the Sony's keep your hands off those but
these are definitely impressive to me
worth checking out I'll show you why so
I got the blue ones but there are a
bunch of colors including yes matte
black everything and matte red and as a
dark blue I don't the sky blue just a 30
guys off but every one of these colors
is a matte finish
soft touch all the way around and they
show absolutely no fingerprints anywhere
they're just really well built this is
one of my complaints about early beats
when they were just these like thin
glossy plastic bands that just broke
super easily this is basically the
opposite the top band is sturdy now
there's actually metal in the side
pieces and I just by sliding these metal
pieces up or down to the size of your
head and it's rigid like these are my
favorite build of Beats headphones
actually of all time but I also think
that that biggest improvement may have
also led to this headphones biggest
downside which is comfort these are on
ear headphones first of all and they
simply don't adjusts very much like they
move around a little bit but not a whole
ton like some others and they're
generally just a lot more rigid
partially because of that metal and
that's the number one reason they're
uncomfortable is because they sit right
on your ears and the clamp force is
tight and like sometimes when the clamp
force of headphones is too tight and you
know it you can sort of where you sort
of break them in after a while these
haven't really
had that effect they've sort of stayed
rigid which means they're built well and
they won't break but it's still kind of
uncomfortable so I found I could wear
these for a couple hours and it didn't
really get worse over that time but
they'd pretty much right away be a bit
uncomfortable because they're squeezing
my ears but once you've got them on that
is actually where the fun starts they
turn on automatically when you open them
and they turn off actually right when
you close them which is a pretty good
mechanism there's no on/off button so
you never leave them on by accident and
kill the battery and once they're on
there's really just one controller and
it's the d-pad on the right-hand side
and it controls everything
one push for play pause you've got a
double tap for the next track triple tap
for the previous and you can also volume
up or volume down and then the little
button on the left can turn on or off
transparency mode and the noise
cancellation is pretty good like better
than I expected you turn it on and you
can immediately hear everything drying
out it's great with background noise
great with public transit and awesome on
a plane
and the way they actually sound is good
yeah these beats sound good it's not
like the previous solos which have been
some just super bass heavy overwhelming
garbage these are a totally different
world I'd actually say they sound pretty
fun now don't get me wrong they're still
heavier on the bass and the highs less
on the mids which can make it sound a
little bit shrill if you're used to
flatter or more neutral sounding
headphones but in general for most
people these will sound bright and clear
and vivid like a photo from a samsung
phone you actually get a decent amount
of isolation from the way these cups sit
on your ears too even though they're not
over ear but mainly that's because they
clamp so hard so yeah if you're still
someone who's worried about beats
because they might sound terrible you
don't have to worry about that anymore
but I'll still say the Sony's bows and
Sennheiser premium noise cancelling
headphones
I still think all sound better than
these but I mean that's pretty much it I
mean their headphones like how many
features can you have the transparency
mode which uses the microphones to let
you hear what's around you instead of
cancelling that sound works very well
and the soft case they come in it's just
that it's a soft case so I'll say that's
fine for me because I keep them in a
backpack and a compartment by themselves
but of course being soft it's not super
protective so if you're tossing it in a
travel bag with some other things be
careful and then the main thing left is
battery life which on these is excellent
40 hours with noise cancellation off and
20 hours of listening with noise
cancellation or transparency mode on I
just did a pair of cross-country flights
about five hours each average and I wore
these the whole time it was pretty
uncomfortable but I wore these the whole
time and I was left with about 46
percent after all that so that about
checks out so that's great battery life
and they also fast charge so you can add
up if you plug these in I think about an
hour of listening from being plugged in
for five minutes the only bummer is that
they charge via lightning which I guess
if you're an iPhone user already is not
that much of a bummer but for someone
like me who paired them with an iPad pro
and an Android phone I would have been
great if they also used USB type-c
like those two things but I mean these
are beats they're made by Apple I don't
even know why I get hopes up for that
type of thing but anyway I'm gonna say
these are my second favorite beats ever
I'm still gonna say my favorite beats
are the power beats Pro those are still
a kick-ass pair of workout headphones
they actually fit and stand my ears and
you can run around and do all kinds of
crazy stuff so I love the power beats
Pro but yeah as far as actual headphones
that beats have made there's my favorite
yet I just wish they were more
comfortable and I just keep I'm so happy
that I'm pleasantly surprised with the
sound for 300 bucks these are
competitive you know there's the 250 to
400 dollar premium noise cancelling
headphone world out there like I said
I'm still gonna switch back to my Sony's
yes clone I'm into the Sony's because
they are more comfortable on their over
ear and they sound just a little bit
better but there is no problem with
these beats either way it's worth noting
there is a pair of over ear noise
cancelling beats that I'm I have to
check out but in general I'm impressed
with these good job beats or good job
Apple I guess with these I'll be looking
forward to the next pair maybe there's a
pair of wireless matte black beats Pro
coming
that would be that'll be kind of sick
actually either way hey thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
it's tech tech vember techno tech member
that's that doesn't roll off the tongue
as well but it's happening catch you
guys in the next one peace